what i wouldn't give to be stuck in an
endless time loop with chloe bennett
god damn so agents of shield has just
dropped its ninth episode
and there's a lot to talk about
throughout this video we'll be going
through the ins and outs of it
as well as everything that you need to
know about the ending obviously there
will be heavy spoilers here
so if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend that you turn off now
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoyed
the video and make sure you subscribe to
the channel for breakdowns on the show
week by week
as always this is the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
episode nine is actually elizabeth
henstridge's directorial debut
the actor plays simmons in the show but
this time she
stepped behind the camera to give one of
the funnest episodes in shield history
we join daisy as she wakes up inside the
healing chamber on board the zephyr
with susa at her side it seems like
everything's gonna be okay
but she quickly realizes that she's been
living the same moments over and over
again messing with time travel has
overloaded the time drive
and because they jumped whilst jumping
the group have become
caught in a wormhole that resets the day
after a certain amount of time
daisy and coulson must get to the bottom
of what's going on
and discover who's been killing all of
the crew and how to fix the time drive
now as with most time loop stories we
replay the same moments over and over
to comedic effect however where shield
does stuff differently
is that it also uses this opportunity to
mess with several of the characters in
interesting ways
mack is blinded by a radiation flare
which
destroys his eyes and they take him to
see gemma who opens up a draw with
medical equipment in there
now amongst these we can also see some
of dick's aftershave
which is called tattletail for men a
tattletail is of course someone who
reveals secret information
and not to jump too far ahead but i love
how this episode is sort of about
covering up secret information at all
costs
so this is a nice little easter egg
there's also a rubik's cube which is of
course something that's extremely
difficult to solve
i think this might be a metaphor for the
entire episode which is sort of like a
puzzle that daisy and coulson must
figure out in order to win
a fire breaks out on the ship and daisy
goes to stop it which is when she sees
the time drive overloading and the day
resets once more
the events happen in similar fashion
with us even getting the title sequence
again
with all these stylized ones we've had
over the past couple of weeks
and actually forgotten what the original
was like so it was good seeing it play
out here
since this episode isn't era specific
she saves
mac and this time instead of going to
stop the fire she visits coulson
who is where we left him last time
recharging in the chronicle chamber
the day resets again and this time she
rushes to him first
to discover he's already aware of what's
going on he explains that she's died
over 14
times now they've actually been through
this loop at least 87
the fact that the two were in healing
chambers is why they're able to remember
what's going on
and thus they have consciousness of the
events that are playing out
even though he's a machine he's slowly
going mad
and i love how we get a ton of father
and daughter moments between the two in
this entry
so far in my opinion this season has
kind of brushed off their surrogate
relationship
and daisy has very much been relegated
to a teammate
rather than the main protagonist that
she used to be however
this episode puts the focus back on her
and it's great to see her actually
getting some agency
beyond wanting to kill absolutely
everybody in the past
he tells her to come back after the next
reset which inevitably happens
when the time drive fires back up she
returns to coulson and he tells her that
every time that a loop happens they go
closer to the vortex
and thus they're running out of time now
you might have noticed that every time
deke mentions the distance from the
wormhole it's slightly shorter
the first time i really noticed this is
when it jumps from 76 kilometers to 67
but every time he pops up on screen the
number gets less and less
now the reason that daisy doesn't
remember some of the loops
and what happened in them is because in
the ones in which she dies
her memory resets most of the times that
we see her she remembers what's going on
simply because she's just continuing the
loop and not being killed
but the times that she does die it
completely wipes the slate clean
in the next loop she goes to the deck
and proves that they're caught in one by
predicting events as they happen
she then informs deek who goes to
simmons to convince her to remove the
memory implant from a brain
in case you've been stuck in your own
time lube and don't remember simmons had
a memory implant put in the back of the
neck
which blocked specific parts of her
memory this is because she knows the
location of fits
aka the big question on everyone's lips
and if she were captured or tortured
she'd be unable to give up this
information
daisy says that if they remove the
implant they'll be able to get the
information
and the loop will reset which will put
things back in place
but this comes into contention and
actually costs a member of the crew
their life
in one of the saddest saddest moments
ever now
in order to prove that the loop is
happening to simmons the latter asks her
to say the first made-up word that pops
into their heads
they go with phlebotom and this actually
has a really cool meaning behind it
the full definition of the word is an
impossible or imaginary device
which is used to move the plot of a tv
show book or film
forward according to google it's science
it's magic
it's strange unknown things to signs or
magic
the reader does not know how phlebotomy
works and the creators hope that he or
she doesn't care
so yeah great little meta joke by the
writers of the show
simmons locks herself in a chamber and
goes to remove it
but even attempting it causes her to die
which is the first death in the episode
so yeah we're gonna need another
strategy this time
daisy goes in with her but she dies
alongside simmons
and enoch discovers a leak in a gas pipe
it's always the one you least suspect
now daisy goes through the entire spiral
of loops again
and gets back up to speed before going
to enoch deke and simmons
to question who it is that's been
killing the crew they attempt to get
yo-yo
who can speedster out of her neck
however this point becomes null and void
when we realize the time it would take
to get her out the quinjet
the loop will have reset it's almost
like they put the one character who
could
solve the entire situation in a place
where they'd be unable to help
some some might say it's lazy writing
but never mind anyway
daisy realizes that someone has been
rummaging through simmons draw
due to the fact that the tattletail
aftershave is on the side
and thus it's tattletailing that someone
is messing with them
it seems like the extraction tool has
had something funny done to it
and before daisy goes to grab it souza
says he will sacrifice
himself so that she doesn't lose her
memory as predicted he dies
and daisy wakes up once more but leaves
him asleep so that he doesn't have to go
through that again
if you've been keeping up to date with
our breakdowns then you'll know that
we've been shipping
souza and daisy from the start and i
love how they actually get their moment
in this episode
the writers pretty much built up their
romance across six episodes
and executed it without it feeling
forced or unearned in my opinion
here it really works and i'm glad that
souza finally found someone after losing
out on peggy carter
to my main man steve rogers must suck at
losing a girl to someone that's been
presumed dead for over 70 years
but they don't call him susa the loser
for nothing
yeah they don't call him that but you
know i'm i'm not a nice person
now their ship is actually named susie
which was confirmed by henstridge so
yeah
susie it works and yeah we love you
susie
now mirroring this colton has a real
heart to heart with daisy
and he says it's soul crushing seeing
everyone die over and over again
this mirrors daisy's point of view on
the situation with coulson too
as she's had to watch your father figure
die time and time again throughout the
series
it's a really heartbreaking moment and
you kind of get the feeling that coulson
wishes he wasn't forced to come back
over and over again and lived through
the same tragedies
because he's unable to tell whether the
emotions that he's going through are
real or not
due to his programming he deduces that
the only other machine on board
aka enoch 2 must have programming that
he's unaware of
this leads him to draw the conclusion
that enoch is the killer
and that he's been doing it
subconsciously to protect the secret of
fitz's location
though he initially seems unaware they
test this theory
and even upon attempting to remove the
implant he goes into full terminator
mode
and reveals that his programming means
he must protect the implant at all costs
this sets off a fun scene in which they
try and distract enoch from discovering
them removing the implant
and there's some absolutely hilarious
moments we also see them resting against
max motorbike
which did pop up earlier in the season
and they do whatever they can to
distract him
even getting the whole team involved he
kicks the crap out of them and yeah i
absolutely love this part of the episode
i'm sorry deke but
your death was quite funny now after a
heart to heart with souza
they realize they need to rally the
troops together and get
certain members of the team to fight
enoch in order to buy them some time
they manage to remove the implant which
causes simmons to reveal the secret
and with a full memory back she can
recall that enoch has an
electorum displacement mechanism within
him
that will fix the time drive she begins
to cry
and remembers all of the memories that
she shut out but before the group can
ask any more questions the time loop
begins again
now something clearly bad is going to be
revealed
and simmons even says what have i done
before
saying no so it does look like
something big is coming now personally i
believe that this might have something
to do with her and fitz's daughter
if you've been watching our video so far
then you'll know that we theorize that
fitz will be an old man
by the time we catch back up with him as
he will have gone the long way round
whilst the agents travel through time
gemma's implant is called diana
i think that this might actually be a
clue that it's named after the daughter
that the pair had
which the memory suppressant is also
protecting diana may be with fitz
and gemma could be upset because she's
abandoned the two to go off and do
missions
which would also be heartbreaking for
the character now we don't know for
definite but that's what i'd lean
towards at the moment
but obviously leave your theories in the
comments section below
the ship jumps again and deke reveals
that they're less than one kilometer
from the vortex on a dime this episode
changes from being this fun little time
loop
to something much more dramatic and we
watch as the group
gather around enoch to sacrifice his
life he has one job
one last job and they have one of the
most devastating send-offs with enoch
before he dies
it sucks seeing him go but he removes
the electoral
trump displacement mechanism without
question
and sacrifices himself enoch was willing
to do what needed to be done in order to
save the family that he's come to know
and love
and he does it without a second's
thought watching him slump down
is devastating and i'm not crying you're
crying
enoch says that he never used to feel
lonely when watching humans
however since meeting the shield agents
he's come to grow and be scared of
losing them
watching enoch die also makes coulson
realize that
he does have something worth living for
and enoch passes away
thinking of his best friend fitz it's a
really heartfelt moment
and he also reveals that he's seen the
future and knows that the team
will not survive now this is obviously
alluding to the fact that this is the
final season
and though hopefully we get that agents
of sword spin-off
you know what even if we don't this has
been such a good send-off that
i can't be mad at them for taking a step
back also i don't know if it's me but
did anyone think that the regulator
looked a lot like an arc reactor
anyway the ship is saved and they escape
the loop which ends this adventure
from here we jump over to malik who's
training cora
aka daisy soft sister and we see her
breaking wineglasses on a table now why
this is important is because
it's actually a play on an earlier scene
in the series in which daisy tested her
powers
in that scene she made music from the
wine glasses whereas
cora completely destroys them showing
the difference between the two
they then tease that they're going after
daisy and we cut to black
which ends the episode now for the next
part of the video we will be talking
about the trailer for next week
so if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend that you turn off now
anyway it looks like it's going to be a
very male eccentric entry
and it does seem that he's slowly
starting to build the army that was
teased in last week's entry there's a
mysterious new character in this trailer
and i think that this might actually be
a younger john garrett
aka bill paxton it seems very similar to
him in appearance
so it may be him or a relative but i do
hope that the time in in some way
especially with this being the last
season jaya ying also comes face to face
with daisy
and says something about her seems very
familiar she is of course daisy's mother
and i kind of hope that daisy steers her
away from the dark path
that she eventually goes on looks like
there's going to be a big shot on our
afterlife
we also get a tease of gordon and lee
whose eyes were burned by
cora in the last episode i'm really
hyped to see the conclusion of the arc
that was started in episode 8
and it'll definitely be interesting to
see what direction that the timeline
goes off into
anyway that wraps up this video and i
have to say that this was
another brilliant entry this is probably
one of my favorite episodes so far
and it delivered with everything that i
was hoping for in terms of drama and
comedy
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the ninth episode so make
sure you comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and if you missed our
analysis of the other episodes then make
sure you check them out after this
every month on the 15th we give away
free blu-rays and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning the mcu
infinity saga box set is leave a like
and subscribe with notifications on you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early
and please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chatusana
discord server in the description
or heavyspoilers on twitter if not then
thank you for making it till the end of
this video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care bye peace
[Music]
you